The video game industry has never been more
innovative or exciting.
But with so many great games coming out, it's
inevitable that some games will just slip
through the cracks.
Here's a look at some incredible video games
no one bought.
Vampire: The Masquerade—Bloodlines
Hardly anyone bought Vampire: The Masquerade
- Bloodlines when it came out over a decade
ago.
Vampires weren’t yet sparkly, and the kind
of vampires Bloodlines dealt with were no
longer that popular.
But those that did buy the game are not only
still playing it, but creating their own new
content for it.
That's the kind of passion this hybrid RPG
inspires in its fans with its immersive story
of a vampire who must negotiate a world of
undead clans competing for supremacy.
It remains a great treat for retro gamers,
but be careful: even now, the hotel level
is scary enough to cause nightmares, so play
at your own risk.
Panzer Dragoon Saga
After two traditional rail shooters, the Panzer
Dragoon franchise took an unexpected detour
into the realm of Final Fantasy style RPGs
with this classic 1998 release.
Panzer Dragoon Saga has been acclaimed as
one of the greatest RPGs of all time.
So why didn't anyone buy it?
Well, it had the misfortune of being released
for the Sega Saturn in 1998 - the same year
the platform was discontinued in North America.
Talk about bad timing!
Psi-Ops: The Mindgate Conspiracy
In this one-and-done adventure from 2004 for
the Xbox and PS2, players assume control of
an amnesiac with psychic powers and a nefarious
paramilitary group on his tail.
It may not sound particularly innovative now,
but that's because dozens of games have since
copied its mind-bending telekinetic gameplay.
Sadly, fans of the game never got a sequel,
and likely never will, as the studio behind
Psi-Ops closed in 2010.
Deadly Premonition
Lots of games get mixed reviews, but Deadly
Premonition actually earned the Guinness World
Record as the Most Critically Polarizing Survival
Horror Game.
Taking many cues from Twin Peaks and Japanese
horror, Deadly Premonition is a must-play
title for fans of B-movies and anyone wanting
a bizarre, left-field experience.
You have to buy gas for your car; without
coffee, you'll get sleepy.
On top of this, the graphics aren't great
even for 2010, and the combat system is terrible.
In other words, it's not for everyone.
But if you don't hate it, chances are you're
going to love it.
With Deadly Premonition, there's really no
middle ground.
Viking: Battle for Asgard
There's something to be said for a game of
mindless destruction spent mowing down enemies
like weeds.
Sure, it might not break new ground, but if
you want to break some skulls instead, this
is your game.
Lost in the shuffle among more hyped and more
innovative titles, Viking: Battle for Asgard
just does one simple thing - but it does it
very, very well indeed.
The Saboteur
The final game from developer Pandemic Studios,
The Saboteur is an open-world game set during
World War II, sort of like Grand Theft Auto
in German-occupied France.
With noir-inspired graphics and an unusual
story-based style that sees you inspiring
rebellion against the Nazi overlords, The
Saboteur feels about as far from cookie cutter
World War II shooters as possible.
And that's a good thing.
Vanquish
Run and gun, duck and cover, punch giants
in the face: It's not just the mantra of this
fast paced third person shooter, it's also
a motto for life.
Vanquish doesn't necessarily do anything new,
but it does everything well, with the controls
and graphics all top notch for a last generation
actioner.
Fans at the time thought it looked too derivative
of games like Bayonetta, but sometimes, fun
trumps innovation.
This is one of those times.
Brütal Legend
Designer Tim Schaefer previously brought gamers
idiosyncratic titles like Psychonauts and
Grim Fandlango.
And this is no exception.
A rock and roll love letter featuring the
likes of and Ozzy Osbourne and Lemmy Kilmister
from Motörhead among its voice cast, Brütal
Legend finds your lowly roadie player character
and their party roaming across a heavy metal
hellscape, securing territory through real-time
combat and strategy.
The game, while a poor seller, was praised
for its wit and charm.
Check it out - and rock on!
Singularity
Singularity is a first-person shooter with
a heady time manipulation mechanic that allows
you to travel forward and backward through
time, affecting gunplay and the convoluted
plot.
Accused of being a BioShock knockoff when
it was released, this entertaining romp is
still worth a run-through for some memorable
moments and nightmarish monsters - and if
you can find some friends to join you for
multiplayer, even better.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!